ça y est c'est officiel l'équipe
d'Irlande de rugby prendra bien ses
quartiers à Tours tours camp de base du
15 du Trèfle pour la Coupe du monde qui
se déroulera en France en septembre 2023
les collectivités qui ont bataillé pour
faire venir les Irlandais en Touraine
compte bien en profiter pour créer des
événements autour de la compétition
c'est annonce tardait à être officialisé
ces choses faites depuis 17h Audrey
Champigny vous êtes devant l'hôtel de
ville de Tours ou la conférence de
presse vient de s'achever
oui bonsoir Mickaël effectivement la
conférence de presse il y a encore un
petit peu de lumière ça mange des petits
fours là encore juste derrière moi mais
vous l'avez dit c'était un secret de
polichinelle mais ça y est c'est
officiel regardez juste derrière moi
l'hôtel de ville de Tours était éclairé
aux couleurs du drapeau irlandais du
vert du blanc et du orange parce
qu'effectivement vous l'avez dit tour
sera irlandais en 2023 un match qui a
été remporté haut la main par la ville
et il faut savoir que la mêlée était
aussi un petit peu serrée puisqu'il y
avait Chartres Blois Bourges dedans
alors on a demandé tout simplement au
président de la Fédération irlandaise de
rugby pourquoi avoir choisi tour on
l'écoute
tout ce dont ils ont besoin pour être
dans les meilleures conditions pour
cette Coupe du Monde
c'est une ville magnifique de ce que
j'ai pu en voir
les équipements sont super et cela leur
permet d'avoir un véritable pôle d'où
ils peuvent voyager pour leur match et
ça c'était crucial pour l'équipe
d'Irlande
il voulait se sentir comme à la maison
pour ne pas avoir à changer d'hôtel ou
de stage
mais c'est vraiment une très belle ville
une belle région donc pourquoi ne pas
choisir tour
alors autant vous dire que et bien si
les Irlandais sont très heureux de venir
ici à Tours l'an prochain et bien les
tours en jours eux sont surexcités toute
la ville va se draper de blanc et de
vers l'an prochain un véritable
événement qui doit beaucoup aussi à
l'entente des différentes collectivités
la ville la métropole la région et le
département on écoute Eric Thomas
adjoint au sport à la ville de Tours
c'est une belle victoire après plus de
18 mois d'un long travail dans le
travail qui porte ses fruits puisqu'on
va livrer un très bel équipement des
nouveaux vestiaires à la chambrerie
qui permettront ensuite à lui est tout
rugby qui est le club de rugby de la
région centre le plus important de
bénéficier de ces équipements et donc
d'accueillir les jeunes filles les
jeunes garçons les amateurs du rugby et
puis de vivre leur passion et auparavant
évidemment l'équipe d'Irlande qui nous
fera l'honneur de sa de sa présence à
tour à partir de fin août 2023 pendant
un mois le mois des compétitions en
poule donc c'est une formidable nouvelle
pour pour nous pour l'équipe municipale
et pour le territoire
alors vous l'avez compris on ne lésine
pas quand on reçoit la meilleure nation
mondiale de rugby près de 4 millions
d'euros à investir Eric Thomas l'a dit
pour améliorer et bien le site de la
chambreerie et puis les irlandaises
seront accueillies comme des princes au
château Belmont à Tours Nord un hôtel 4
étoiles à 4 étoiles pardon où ils
pourront se reposer et reprendre des
forces entre les matchs le château
Belmont qui avait déjà accueilli
l'équipe de foot tchèque pendant l'Euro
2016 malheureux malheureusement éliminé
en face de poule alors un destin peu
probable pour le 15 irlandais meilleur
national cette saison et qui a battu
samedi les Springbox lors de sa tournée
d'automne alors on va justement un petit
peu parler rugby avec Bertrand Bourgeaud
qui va nous rejoindre juste à côté de
nous Bertrand bonsoir vous êtes un peu
le monsieur rugby de la ville de Tours
vous êtes aussi le président de de tout
rugby 2023-2024 tout simplement les
Irlandais arrivent l'an prochain à Tours
est-ce que les Irlandais peuvent gagner
cette coupe du monde sans aucun problème
l'Irlande le cas du Trèfle fait partie
des grands prétendants au titre de
champion du monde pour l'année prochaine
leur victoire effectivement samedi
dernier à la Viva Stadium face aux
tenant du titre springbok on est le plus
bel exemple c'est une équipe extrêmement
complète dans toutes les lignes et qui
va amener la vie dure à toutes les
équipes
de l'hémisphère nord de l'hémisphère sud
et notamment de l'équipe de France parce
que je pense quand même que les Bleus
ont une belle chance également de se
mêler à la lutte finale et pourquoi pas
une finale France - Irlande pour nous la
ville de Tours ça serait formidable
alors Eric Thomas tout à l'heure
l'adjoint au sport nous disait là les
travaux de la chambreerie ça va
bénéficier évidemment aux Irlandais mais
après et bien tous les petits joueurs de
rugby pourront aussi en bénéficier et ça
c'est super vous qui êtes un peu le
monsieur rugby de lui est tour
ouais ben justement c'est ça le gros le
gros avantage pour l'UST c'est que tous
les travaux qui ont été faits par la
ville de Tours et je les en remercie
comme la métropole et tout et de même
l'État qui a financé tout ce superbe
projet ça va être un peu l'héritage pour
le club de l'ESTO et ça c'est formidable
parce que quand on voit ce club repris
il y a 4-5 ans par Benoît sébiller et on
est en train de remonter une à une les
marches on occupe le haut de tableaux en
fédéral 2 pour le moment on veut pas le
dire on a de l'ambition mais ce qui est
formidable c'est je me mets à la place
moi en tant qu' ancien joueur de l'US
tour je me rappelle quand j'étais mon on
avait les yeux qui écarquillaient quand
vous voyez des joueurs des joueurs de
Renault des internationaux et tout mais
là je vois pour en avoir parlé avec des
jeunes de l'école de rugby et tout c'est
formidable l'engouement qui peut y avoir
et je pense que c'est le meilleur des
cadeaux qu'on veut qu'on pouvait leur
offrir parce qu'il rêve que d'une seule
chose c'est de pouvoir approcher
justement ces irlandais qui vont être
pendant 5 semaines chez nous et une des
grandes priorités ça va être justement
de pouvoir convaincre bon ça c'est une
autre paire de manches les Irlandais
pour pouvoir ouvrir les entraînements et
qui est gamin puissent venir approcher
des joueurs comme sextoy toutes leurs
idoles on a tous été jeune et ça me
ramène quelques années en arrière et je
pense que c'est un superbe et c'est une
promotion énorme ça va être un coup de
bouche pour lui est tour et ben écoutez
on va finir sur ces mots du d'un
passionné de l'US tour et de rugby on va
attendre que ça passe juste derrière
nous voilà on va finir avec ces quelques
mots de passionnés de rugby vous voyez
Bertrand il a déjà l'écharpe il a déjà
le petit pin's de l'Irlande on le
rappelle à la coupe du monde de rugby
2023 c'est du 8 septembre au 28 octobre
2023 vous avez un an pour vous mettre au
vert les tours en jeu la marée verte va
déferler sur
à bientôt
Audrey on compte sur vous pour une
troisième mi-temps mais un peu mesuré
quand même